hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt heute möchte ich eines
alegre tor zu machen und zwar ist der
nächste woche muttertag und ich finde
zum muttertag gehört eigentlich immer
auch nicht selbst gemachter torte
letztes jahr habe ich ja bereits ohne
motiv trotte gemacht die verlinke ich in
meiner infobox ich habe letztes jahr
auch eine richtig leckere joghurt et
wäert heute gemacht und heute möchte ich
jetzt natürlich auch wieder eine
erdbeertorte machen aber eine mit kokos
also ich liebe sowieso die kombination
aus erdbeeren und kokos sowie ihn zu
einem eisbecher beispiel mal so wir
hatten es spaghetti eis ist ist immer
kokos stress lauf der etwas lose finde
ich total lecker deswegen heute diese
kombination
ich versuche auch relativ einfach zu
halten obwohl beides ist kein einfaches
rezept ist also kein leichtes aber es
kann im prinzip jeder nachmachen als er
braucht dafür und handrührgerät und dann
eben einfach eure zutaten und ich starte
jetzt einfach mit meiner wiener masse
also mit dem biskuitteig und seid euch
kurz die zutaten
ich brauche nämlich dafür sechs eier
eine prise salz
ich habe hier 200 gramm zucker 90 gramm
mehl 1 teelöffel backpulver 60 gramm
speisestärke und 80 gramm kokosraspeln
und hier habe ich bereits 60 gramm
zerlassene butter
die apps sind jetzt grad nur deko die
benutze ich natürlich später aber ich
zeige euch später nochmal die zutaten
für die creme und so weiter und für die
ganze deko und jetzt gebe ich zuerst mal
die eier die sind zimmer waren gebe ich
hier ihm eine rührschüssel gleich ein
eingriff aufgegangen so und wenn sie
zimmer waren sie lassen es sich halt
super verrühren und es gab dann perfekt
dann die prise salz mit dazu
und gleich auch den zugang und dann
lassen wir das jetzt richtig schön
cremig rühren und es kann jetzt echt so
zwischen fünf und zehn minuten dauern
mit dem handrührgerät halt eben genauso
lang oder sogar noch länger
die eier zucker mars ist jetzt richtig
schön aufgeschlagen und jetzt kann ich
die trockenen zutaten mit dazu geben
also hier für mich jetzt kurz in meinem
sieht nähe mit der speisestärke und dem
backpulver dann gibt es nämlich auch
gleich keine klumpen und ich habe eine
schöne feine bis geteilt gebe ich aber
auch direkt die kokosraspeln mit dazu
deswegen gibt so ein richtig schönes
aroma und das habe ich jetzt kurz unter
und gebt dann gleich noch die butter
betreiben also dann ist jetzt richtig
schön vorsichtig arbeite einfach schön
unterstreichen
ohne jetzt nach der 3
wer möchte könnte jetzt hier noch
bisschen aroma dazu geben entweder im
fokus liegt zum beispiel stelle ich mir
richtig gut und lecker vor oder etwas
amaretto oder einfach bittermandel aroma
also das geht auch das wäre dann die
alkoholfreie variante und halten mandl
sirup was er auch alkoholfrei ist da
versuchen nicht so lange zu hören
aber halt doch solange das man halt kein
mehl mehr sieht und das will ich jetzt
hier meine springform ich habe sie einen
bug rahmen auf 26 cm gestellt ich habe
diese verstellbaren die hat sogar
praktisch sind weil das halt auch
richtig schön hoch ich glaube da ist
zehn zentimeter hoch kann ich eine
schöne hohe torten immer drin backen und
kann mit rahmen so einstellen wie ich
ihn hat braucht und da ist halt nur
wichtig dass ihr vorher den wagramer mit
der das backpapier einschlag dann läuft
nämlich auch kein tag aus jetzt kann ich
den rahmen einfach zum backen benutzer
und später dann eben auch für die creme
also später dann also tortenring
verstreichen muss ich zunächst ist alles
schön verlaufen
und jetzt wird der teig gebacken im
backofen klar wo auch sonst bei 160 grad
ober und unterhitze vorgeheizt moser
sein
oder brauchen so etwa 35 bis 40 minuten
wobei ich jetzt kürzer backen muss weil
ich habe dieses backblech mit den
löchern drin und da habe ich einfach
viel weniger backzeit also das geht dann
alles immer auch viel schneller und das
mache ich jetzt kurz und die
zwischenzeit nutze ich dann gleich ein
bisschen von der creme und von adecco
vorzubereiten
ich kann jetzt in deshalb schaue meine
zwei krebs vorbereiten und zwar habe ich
einmal einen etwa spiegel und einmal
eine kobus krebs ist unsere kokos
zahncreme und das stelle ich jetzt schon
mal her weil ich die zwei gleich noch
kühl stellen muss also für die sp masse
brauche ich erdwärme sind 250 gramm
bereits entsteht auch also das grüne
erschreckt die habe ich zwei esslöffel
speisestärke ich brauche eine zitrone
davon die schale und den saft ist eine
bio zitrone etwas vanille extrakt und
drei esslöffel wasser und für die kokons
creme dann nämlich eine dose kokosmilch
ich brauch 200 gramm weiße schokolade
400 gramm sahne und 500 gramm aska pole
und 75 gramm chorisch blocken und wer
möchte kann es noch nach süßen mit
puderzucker
aber ich denke dass die schokolade schon
süß genug ist und der torten ebenso eine
leichte süße gibt ich starte jetzt
zuerst mal mit den erdbeeren
ich stelle jetzt auch die sahne und dem
abholen noch mal kalt bzw der morath
macht es und ich kann hier
weiterarbeiten
zuerst gebe ich jetzt die speisestärke
mit zum wasser und das versuche ich
jetzt mit einem kleinen teich aber ich
vergesse auszulegen einfach so bissig
verrühren
dann gehen nämlich auch diese klümpchen
weg und das hilft dann auch gleich dabei
dass diese erb dass das apple für so ein
bisschen fest wird also das ist halt ein
bisschen stockte mir so eine art pudding
hier moment hier gebe ich erstmals die
zitronenschale rein
man könnte jetzt auch in die mitte
nehmen also was ihr halt lieber habt
zitrone oder limette ich finde beides
richtig gut vor allem ich beides richtig
sommerlich und frisch und dann kann ich
nämlich die zitrone gleich noch
auspressen und dann gemeinsam den
zitronensaft mit den erdbeeren
zusammenleben pürieren
ihr könnt auch hier gern etwas nach
süßen mit etwas zucker oder puderzucker
aber ich finde so eine torte da vorne zu
sein also wenn ich sehe mir immer viel
zu mächtig und man kann sie dann einfach
abschmecken und je nachdem wie süß eben
das obst ich kann man auch dazu gewonnen
hatte
einmal durch kurieren
also ich bin so business stück ich darf
schon noch bleiben deswegen führe ich
das jetzt nicht ganz klar
das reicht schon und gibt auch gleich
diese stärke mischung mit da rein und
koche dass jetzt gleich zusammen auf
und diese mischung die gebe ich hier in
einem kleinen topf so riecht auch
richtig lecker fruchtig und es kann
jetzt einfach vor sich hin
das mache ich gleich und kann es schon
noch mal zeige das kann ich schon mal
zeigt was ich mit der kokosmilch mache
und zwar habe ich das hier zum gewissen
vorbereitet bei kokosmilch ist das so da
erstanden vor allem in die bisschen
länger steht in der abstellkammer ich
oben so dieser feste masse also dieses
ganze fett und unten dann die
flüssigkeit
außerdem ist richtig gut schütteln und
erschreckt euch nicht wenn ihr das auch
noch von oben ist einfach alles fest
sondern schüttet einfach alles gemeinsam
in den topf habe ich jetzt schon gemacht
und hab es dann aufkochen lassen und
jetzt ist das ganze schon reduziert also
man sieht jetzt auch das ist jetzt keine
400 milliliter mehr
ich habe es etwa 10 minuten lang köcheln
lassen und kochte es jetzt auch gleich
noch mal auf das ist manchmal so etwa
zwei minuten ein reduzieren und dann
gebe ich dann nämlich gleich die weiße
schokolade mit ihr kann man da drin
scheint schneller und das hier kaufe ich
jetzt auch kurz auf
also die erdbeeren
also die kokons mit ihr ist es wieder
aufgedruckt und ich lasse jetzt bei
mittlerer stufe noch mittel weiterkochen
ich habe übrigens vergessen dass familie
extrakt mit zu dem erdbeben zu geben
ja auch noch ein paar tropfen mit rein
riecht und schmeckt dann einfach sehr
lecker und man sieht jetzt hier auch
schon dass es auch schon eingedeckt ist
also so wissel pudding artig geworden
ist ich lasse es jetzt auch bei
mittlerer stufe noch bisschen kochen und
jetzt sieht man deutlich dass die milch
auch schon wieder weniger geworden ist
also richtig konzentriert jetzt schalte
ich die kokosmilch aus also den herd aus
da wurde cookies mit draufsteht und gibt
die weiße schokolade mit rein dass man
das einfach auflösen einfach rühren bis
sie sich aufgelöst hat und dann muss
noch weit es gleich abkühlen lassen
meine grenzen jetzt beide kalt und jetzt
kann ich schon mal die sahne creme
herstellen da bist du dich auch schon
abgekühlt ja oder aber trotzdem noch mal
kurz in den kühlschrank gegeben und
jetzt werde ich hier in dieser schlüssel
einmal die sahne schlagen
da kommen jetzt noch vier teelöffel
seiner partner zwei und hier im mixer
also jenen der kitchenaid da mache ich
die mascarpone creme
ich meine es wird eine creme ich muss
halt mascarpone und sahne getrennt
voneinander aufschlage und das mache ich
jetzt eben kurz und dann hole ich gleich
dieser kokos creme aus dem kühlschrank
die ich nämlich noch im kühlschrank
damit sie einfach schön kalt ich wenn
ich sie gleich zusammen mit dazu gemacht
die sahne steif und jetzt höre ich hier
noch die mascarpone creme so auf
mittlerer stufe herab ohne darf nicht zu
lange rühren und gibt da auch bis hin zu
einer parteien gerade so zwei telefone
höher
denn da kommt jetzt gleich die
schokocreme mit rein
und jetzt gebe ich die sanicare einlass
aber auch so etwa 100 bis 150 gramm
übrig
die brauche ich dann später zum
dekorieren der torte dass ich möchte
hier jetzt nämlich ein teil nur aus die
stelle ich gleich kühl und gäbe es hier
zu meiner kokos creme noch die
kokosraspeln mit rein dann kann man
nämlich auch wieso kokos in der creme
schmeckt sogar fast so ähnlich wie ließ
oder raffaello krämer zu dienern so
bisschen durch diese weiße schokolade
die krebsschere ich jetzt ganz kurz kühl
hole meinen bis methoden und ruhe die
rechtliche deko und dann können wir
gleich die torte zusammensetzen
ich habe jetzt hier meinen biskuitteig
bereits in zwei hälften geschnitten und
dass er mit ganz normalem in der toten
könnte es aber auch zum beispiel mit
einem messer machen mit einer großen und
jetzt gebe ich diese erdbeer creme
darauf also wenn euer type hoch genug
wird könnt ihr natürlich auch durch drei
teile
aber irgendwie wollte dabei mir heute
zog deswegen jetzt nur zwei teilen
installiert auch manchmal ein schlechter
tag weil man gelingt es auch nicht immer
so wie sie es sich vorstellt also gut
zwei meter ist die ganze creme drauf
meyer verschwendung
und es riecht auch richtig lecker
erinnert an etwa monate aber ich leider
dazu ist also ich habe das zwar ein
bisschen nach es mit 1 2 esslöffel
butter zucker aber nicht viel weil die
creme ich eigentlich schon richtig süß
genug und der boden ist schön süß jetzt
setzt sich hier einen teig ring wieder
aus herum also dem täterin was macht
kleinen stelle und dann drauf
und dann gebe ich jetzt hier die creme
rein
ihr seht auch die schön fest geworden
also ohne gelatine ohne aktive usw
einfach mit hilfe der schokolade und ein
bisschen salat passt sich hier nur
bisschen auf dass hier die creme also
diese erdbeben nicht am rand geht man
ich möchte jetzt keinen roten rand und
deswegen stehe ich jetzt zuerst mal
diese weise creme in den rand rein weil
sonst habe ich das schläger und quillt
es am rand raus und das wenig halten
damit betraut
jetzt setzt sich hier noch den deckel
drauf so und dann schön an drücke man
könnte wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr euren
bode bissle tränke mit zum beispiel
kosslick oder mandel leckere oder mantel
sirup als er das oder kokos sirup gibt
es glaube ich nicht auf jeden fall
können sie nützlich da mal wenn ihr
wollt muss nicht aber ich denke ich noch
mal so ein typ polieren auf der torte so
und jetzt geben sie einfach den rest
extrem dass ich das noch mal so eine
vierte vielleicht gebe ich noch
obendrauf und streicht es glatt geht am
besten mit so einer kleinen mini palette
kommt man nämlich richtig schön in
diesem tortenring rein
und jetzt habe ich hier ein paar
erdbeeren also die trottel habe ich
jetzt einmal kühl gestellt
das ist hier im warmen in der warmen
küche schmilzt und jetzt nehme ich hier
die erdbeeren
einige habe ich mir jetzt weg gelegt für
obendrauf für die deko ein paar andere
nehme ich jetzt für den rand und zwar
möchte ich nämlich dass der rand auch
schön mit erdbeeren frösche unten
und deswegen muss ich da oben das grüne
mal weg schneider und dann nehme ich die
erdbeere und schneit hier so ein stück
weg und dann ebenso scheibe runde und
schlägt mir jetzt mal die großen und die
kleinen getrennt weg
und die erdbeeren für die oberseite der
tat und die halte ich jetzt nur
jetzt habe ich den trockenen rahmen
entfernen gehen am besten wenn wir
einfach so eine kleine palette nimmt und
an den rahmen eröffnet
das nämlich jetzt auch noch mit
das bestreichen
und jetzt nehme ich etwas kokosflocken
unbedingt jetzt erst mal die ganze torte
damit deswegen ist auch nicht schlimm
wenn die torte jetzt nicht komplett
richtig wunderhübsch eingedeckt ist denn
das überdecken wird was ich übrigens zu
vergessen zu erwähnen ihr braucht gleich
noch ein paar also in einem gleich noch
ein paar moschee kugel
denn die passe einfach perfekt zu der
tat dazu neigen und auch an der hand
dass ich hier muss man wirklich nicht so
exakt arbeiten das kann man alles mit
dem kopf aus einfachen überdecke
dann möchte ich jetzt da oben ein paar
sahnetag vor spritzen und deswegen muss
ich mir gerade so eine kleine runde rein
machen damit dieser überhaupt haften
bleibt weil wegen der kokosflocken wird
jetzt gar nicht dran kleben bleiben und
ich mache jetzt zwölf stücke 12 uhr
teile haben will
die zahl habe ich jetzt bereits in so
einem spritzbeutel mit nach hause
gegeben und spritze jetzt hier so schöne
tipps
da kommen jetzt die kugel noch davor
und ich habe natürlich versucht meint
und der große kuchen ein bisschen fehl
am platz
und die sieht ja jetzt schon gut aus
aber jetzt kommt noch das i-tüpfelchen
es kommen noch die erdbeere und zwar
möchte ich einige hier an der wand
kleben das wege gucke ich auch hier dass
ich ein bisserl von den kokosraspeln
wegnehmen das was man übrigens jetzt
wegnehme dass ich einfach alles später
zum auf nachteil zum naschen mit sonne
mal die ganze cremig schlecker und stadt
gebe ich dir jetzt an den rand schön mit
der schnittkante nach vorne
die torte ist schön kalten ich kenne sie
jetzt schon mal anschneiden
denn meine torte hier ist jetzt nichts
zum muttertag aber ich finde es ist ein
richtig tolles montags rezept
am besten nimmt dir ganz scharfes messer
wenn wir jetzt mal wieder die erdbeere
verdreht kriege ich aber gleich wieder
hin
das muss die torte im innern aus ich
meine so wie im fernsehen dass wir mal
die torte anschneiden dass felix
verschmiert wir halt so wenn man eine
erdbeer sahne torte dann vermischt sich
halt die etwa mit dem normalen sahne
aber nein ich habe das tier schmeckt und
deswegen probieren wir die jetzt
zusammen
murat ist da also habe ich jetzt das
stück für mich alleine und riechen tut
sie schon was sehr gut da muss mit der
kamera bisserl weg halten dass man nein
kann ich ruhig so bin ich schon rede
will oder nicht coco szene
also ich finde die schmeckt ist sehr
lecker alles wieder sauber und ich finde
dass ich dort die solltet ihr auf jeden
fall mal nachmachen
wenn ihr natürlich kokosmilch und
erdbeeren wobei ich kaum jemanden kinder
die kombination network also für mich
ist es echt nach man noch schnee taute
oder neben einem schnitt oder auch noch
mal eine richtig leckere wahlweise als
torte und das stück das hätte ich mir
jetzt auf es sich gleich mit einem
schönen tee und früchtetee oder so und
schießt noch schnell ein foto für
facebook und instagram und wenn ihr
jetzt rezept nach machen wollt dann geht
einfach auf meinem blog auf 6 - blog.de
da gibt es noch mal die zutaten angaben
die mengenangaben und natürlich auch die
zubereitung weise aber das video auch
schon genug
und da wünsche ich euch einfach viel
spaß beim nachbarn und wir sehen uns
beim nächsten mal wieder biss dann
tschüss